on va jouer avec lara fabian on va jouer
sur la vie de lara fabian et on va jouer
à n'oubliez pas les bestioles sais pas
c'est très sain on va jouer avec la vie
de lara fabian un chroniqueur ou même
moi puisque je suis dans la rue je suis
ici je suis en jaune donc ça peut tomber
soit ça peut tomber sur ma poire mathieu
y ait deux fois parce que mathieu est
beau à voir deux fois ta photo voilà je
vous le dis je vais faire tourner la
hora chroniqueurs qui ira se passait
là-bas et il ya diverses choses dans les
tubes
si vous répondez bien pas de problème si
beau répondait mal ce sera une autre
paire de manches c'est sur lara fabian
tout le monde la connaît tout le monde
lève je t'aime comme un fou comme un roi
comme une star de cinéma
c'est parti on y va en fait tourner la
roue à dos et je ne triche pas vous
pouvez venir vérifier 1
regardez regardez regardez il n'y a rien
sakho tombé sur moi
à
il a observé que je vous avais je
voulais pas en parler mais je suis très
très malade et je sais rien pour vous
vous inquiétez pas c'est rien je sais
pas ce cadeau je vais vérifier et on se
parle juste après venez venez vous
inquiétez pas bon juge et on va on veut
on ira sur les voilà on ira aux cinq
sens est le 1 le premier donc c'est sûr
les chaussures mais en changeant prénom
là on va tourner et retourner dans la
vie l'a décidé que cette fois ci je
serai courageux je me suis vu la
dernière fois j'ai été minable hélas
cette fois ci alors tu vas voir en vrai
je voulais mettre sur le net
j'avais déjà une perte au marché je vais
les mettre en style sinon voilà comme ça
aux vaches mondiale bon alors julien on
va vous poser des questions sur lara
fabian
oui à fabian qu'on aime qu'on apprécie
énormément là dedans il y a des choses
alors il ya plein de choses il y a des
trucs sympas ya des trucs moins sympa
julien j'ouvrirai d'abord celle ci pas
que je te dire ne fais pas ton discours
post 2 tu finisses on dit parce que j'ai
j'en peux plus donc ça va tomber là ça
tombera là entre là dans la gencive
j'avais besoin d'un petit peu les issues
quand même là là vous inquiétez pas
alors attention hormis hormis le
français et l'anglais citer trois
langues dans lesquelles lara fabian est
capable de chanter
voilà le français l'anglais oui si tu es
trois langues
un peuple est là c'est la wii c'est la
wii y avoir il doit y avoir là fabien à
la l'italien italien vous dites voilà
je peux le portugais l'espagnol oui la
nasa bien oui je dirais fabiola le russe
maurice
alors attention on va dire que fabian
est ce que vous pouvez dire est ce que
vous pouvez dire c'est très bien joué
julien courbet en italien asuka tout
bénisse immersive attendaient des
détails assez bon asuka tomber lycée
renoir petit toit tout est là face à la
galère ne verrez plus tôt de chez la
fatale à gallargues et la fatala grande
saveur tête à une belle grande gueule
est-ce que vous pouvez le dire en
espagnol
bravo julien combes et c'est très bien
ce que tu as fait je suis évite les
insectes donc est habitué ce qu'elle
fait que tu amènes texaco merci la wii
est maintenant est-ce qu'elle parle le
russe l'a enfin non tu chantes en russe
mais je ne parle pas non mais ce que
vous pouvez chanter en russe oui ce que
je peux le prendre
attention ce pont est en ballottage
favorable parle pas ici alors nous
chanter un chant michel qui dit quoi
soigner certaines chansons après j'ai
hâte veille au bayoud ni retouche
télescope pour moi voilà
cinquante jeunes âgés de question par
personne au temps au tour tout est
vraiment ça va c'était très facile tu es
souffler lorsque lara à vide du monde
chez elle elle leur propose d'enfiler
quelque chose de bien particulier
regarde pas je ne veux pas entrer mais
je ne parle jamais de victoire
de quoi s'agit-il à votre avis qu'est ce
qu'elles demandent
elle demande d'enfiler quelque chose
chez elle a des propositions à non
qu'est-ce que pour filer bd des
chaussons pour bob c'est dire le sol ou
des parce qu'elle est le parc est nickel
vous avez alors je vais vous dire j'ai
entendu parce que j'ai une oreille
sustiva ce qui ferait ça a soufflé à
souffler donc j'annule cette crise
pour la voir
je les ai entendus donc si je l' ai
entendu par transitivité vous l'avez
entendu vous êtes coupable parce que je
te dire juste un truc très rapide ouais
t'es qu'une merde merde
en 2012 lara fabian a débarqué dans une
émission de radio belge avait qu'à pas
nous compléter la phrase julien inscrits
dessus je suis une princesse et je suis
une princesse et je je je vous emmerde
je suis une princesse jamais je prends
je vous emmerde
alors elle vient pas nous il ya juste
mot juste raymond ordre plusieurs bouts
alors et je suis une princesse et reste
la vie quoi mais je suis une princesse
et je vous emmerde
voilà ça a triché aux anneaux et le
regretté georges donc sans tricher je
vous emmerde il est sorti naturellement
oui bah c'est pas sûr que ces spasmes et
naïma trichet
allez
profitons formation ce n'était pas moi
qui dois je ne suis pas là on a pas le
temps valérie depuis patate chaude
non non
allez mettez vous là ne vous inquiétez
pas mâché ses mots
est ce que est ce que oui ou non vous
l'avez souffert que ses gentils sur oui
ou non vous avez su j'aurais sur la tête
de ma mère je jure sur la tête de l'anc
mère parce que j'ai fait des mimes c'est
pas le prix chômage fédé magalas
qu'allez vous le dise le blogueur va
s'occuper de vous la faire allez mettez
vous n'arrêtez pas je vais le mettre là
là haut niveau dès hier justement j'aime
pas je vais pas laisser aller mais tdg
très bel accord mais là il ne fait pas
chaud scott ya pas mal de gens qui se
pètent de vous dans l'établissement mais
naïve voici la question à temps et
articulant à est aussi articule quand tu
pètes dacca lara fabian avoué avoir un
faible pour un acteur français
elle a déclaré il est beau au delà des
traits physiques il est beau dedans il
est beau de dans un 50 minutes inside
alors héron selon se couche on entend
avoir bien que ma voix à temps et
réfléchir
allez vite sinon combien aller dit
l'acteur attend vite c'est j'aurais aimé
chiba allongez-vous dos ne me touche pas
voilà je prendrai allez on y va elle est
trop loin dans des eaux à wow vient
pendant son tube chef mais il a raté la
mets toi mais pourquoi il ne va pas lui
non plus dire après il fera la dernière
qui fait pas peur des bêtes point bas
mais c'est pas que des bêtes il ya des
hommes aussi qu on y va alors les buts
allaient se dit attends attends à les
bleus jeudi sur des jardins non vous
avez triché
grasset
vous trouvez vous me prenez pour
accrocher les gens mélangent
qu'est ce qui se passe ne triche pas ma
chérie années de sanary sérias est très
bon c'est bon allez c'est bon
mathieu de lamotte yoplait
les tchèques jamais refaire tout mais là
on a à peu près tourner la roue ce sera
la dernière question avant que yannick
ovale
ça peut être moi je rappelle que je suis
dans la rue
il a peur peur de bons mets tes cheveux
mais attention écrasé pas les allées
n'écrasez pas d'écraser y compris le
principe
alors attention voici la question pour
quelle nation lara fabian at elle
participé au coup soit bon pour quelle
nation la fin de l'année au bon
millésime pour quelle nation lara fabian
at elle participé au concours de
l'eurovision
ainsi il faudra composer son nom alors
là je suis affirmatif c'est le canada
car maman alors c'est peut-être le
canada y viennent pour l'eurovision
c'est normal elle a terminé
c'est sur larsen
je me bats les applaudissements du
salaire
lannoy lent
merci les séries c'est normal mais
j'aime beaucoup c'est troublant bâtiment
jacques populaire on voit là vous avez
quoi on accueille camille combal et on
va refaire tourner la roue oui c'était
la belgique